we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a very good
question listen to this
hey David why do you think that personal
finance at least very basic concepts
aren't taught in the public school
system in the U.S I'm not sure if other
countries do teach it but just something
as basic as intro to finance something
something simple why isn't that part of
public school system and the curriculum
yeah listen that's a great question
everybody would be so much better off
if personal finance started to be taught
certainly by age 12 if not younger
saving just basically you could start
very early
there's a few different reasons number
one there's the claim that public
schools just can't afford it you know
they say listen we've had to get rid of
woodworking we've had to get rid of a
bunch of sports stuff a bunch of
electives we just don't have the money
for a personal finance class is it true
or not well you know it's all about what
you prioritize but that's one reason
that there aren't such classes another
reason is Teachers lack financial
literacy as well they weren't taught it
either so finding teachers to teach the
class is sometimes a challenge
parents are often not fluent in Money
Matters and they may not even know to
request it as something that should or
could be taught maybe there's a bit of a
taboo around money that's a factor as
well but it would be a great idea to
start teaching personal finance early
I think part of a sign of the demand for
this and the need is how quickly our
finance channel has grown the the Pacman
Finance Channel which we launched about
a month ago youtube.com pacmanfinance it
already has 12 000 subscribers none of
our channels none of our platforms have
ever gotten their first 12 000
subscribers this quickly and I think
it's clearly because there is a need
there is a desire for personal finance
info so find the channel youtube.com
pacmanfinance we've got a great bonus
show for you today producer Pat will
join me if you sign up at joinpakman.com
you will get instant access to that
bonus show